[Music]
so you guys I saw something on Twitter
that is splitting people in their
opinion I hope it's the colors like do
you see it red and whatever all the fun
game stuff no I love that sounds meaner
yeah oh really
yeah okay so this tweet it says you can
truly dodged a bullet with men by
inquiring to reschedule a first date day
of and seeing how they respond so this
chick she ends up sending in a text and
says hey I'm so sorry to even ask this
but how do you feel about a week weekend
date instead of right now we just got
approval to launch a product and it's
happening very quickly and the guy
responded with are you joking I'm
showered ready to go and had planned my
day around this I understand work comes
first but to pull out this late is
pretty disrespectful if you're unable to
respect me or my time then I'm [ __ ]
well and then the emoji and then yeah
that's annoying this is the whole that's
a [ __ ] [ __ ] the guy how late
are we talking so you're a picking guys
I know I'm not even know sign I think
well I said I mean girl side is what the
girls saying truthful because if it's
truthful then I'm like oh I mean oh
that's what it was I saw this on Twitter
- yeah yeah oh you mean like if she's
testing you if she's testing him then
[ __ ] her - that's what people are
commenting and they're saying that
they're like what the [ __ ] like well you
first of all some people are saying what
you did was a red flag already second of
all if you're gonna go out of your way
to have you're a cute little test like
this and that's annoying out yeah yeah
cuz I wouldn't respond like that
but then if someone did message me that
I feel like okay if if the girl message
you go or if the guy message you that I
mean so the the point of that text was
she's doing she's celebrating because of
a launch or something or something she's
pretty much saying that she needs she's
picking work over their dates at this
moment and she's saying I'm so sorry can
we reschedule this I think that's very
mature it depends on how was it eight
forty-five minutes from now
yeah I don't know it
sent at exactly 5 p.m. so I don't know
what time so maybe it was like a 6
o'clock or so oh that is kind of [ __ ]
that's pretty far that is [ __ ] idiot
[ __ ] up but if I were the guy then
like I mean it's a first date I'd be
like yeah like you don't know me like I
can't choose your career that's your
[ __ ] like we don't even know if we're
gonna work out but if I laid it like if
I pursue something and it becomes
serious and I find out she was doing
that [ __ ] to test me I'd be pigs I think
you were looking immature oh yeah I
think the timing thing really plays a
big factor because its own if it's only
an hour it's like [ __ ] you could've
[ __ ] said some [ __ ] like hours ago
what the [ __ ] right but at the same time
though I've know what you're saying if
this was my first tinder date with this
girl and she was like hey sorry some
work she came up then I would just be
like I'd be like alright I get it this
is work you don't know me but also I'd
be like lol but you owe me for for the
next one you know saying this time like
you better like cook me dinner like that
but use it you know I'm saying cuz it's
not that it's like your first tinder day
like who really cares putting those
scenarios like the fact that it's a
first date we're also putting that
ourselves into the situation because we
don't know for a fact yeah cuz for me I
think if I'm just assuming everything
for face value of what I read in both
texts I think there's context that
matters cause like yeah if it's an hour
right after away from their date that
it's kind of messed up but also if
that's something they talked about and
then they're like here oh yeah we're
gonna go on a date right after work but
then that day like you know if you work
in any type of startup [ __ ] pops off at
a tee time or if you work for a media
company and there's breaking news there
are that's like a new logic
all-hands-on-deck like overtime is like
it can happen tomorrow you know so I
think that's true
so for her like if she is a hustler and
she is is like work focused the way she
presented it seemed pretty professional
to me the way that he took it seemed
very bad thing right so guys need to be
careful sometimes I guess girls too but
mostly I see this with guys where you
lash out and make yourself seemed really
insecure yeah that's what he seemed like
no [ __ ] right like this [ __ ] was like
yo um you're obviously not respecting my
time all shits like dude she's like
pretty reasonable
I've never understood like even when
like in movies and [ __ ] when someone's
like oh man I can't make this date
tonight what am I gonna do I'm gonna
[ __ ] this up forever I've never
understood the issue with like yo if
someone was to cancel music cool we'll
do it next week that's a Nikki on our
first it was gonna be our first date and
I had to cancel it because I double
booked myself I'm gonna see Birdemic too
and I was going to the screening with
the [ __ ] director then I was like I'm
not missing the [ __ ] I mean but then I
did what I didn't know was that Nikki
went to the screening too as a result
it's like because we our date didn't
happen she was on you over the day you
pieces she know she didn't know I was
gonna be there I know he picked I picked
for demikhov earn icky
no I'm saying she you guys both had the
invite but she goes no I'm gonna be with
the man of my dreams I'm gonna cancel
that but you said I'm gonna be at the
movie premiere of my dreams he was going
with the director that's nothing I was
going to use the director was there he
gave his speech beforehand
Wow he was moved by his own movie yet he
talked about it but then I sat next to
Nikki there we sat next yeah and you
guys held hands was she well what was
her reaction when she saw you she was
like holy [ __ ] that's what you're going
to I was again haha oh it's perfect cuz
she was [ __ ] in love with you anyway
so it's like better she's just happy
really I didn't know that at the time I
didn't know that love you already
well I don't suppose even getting mad at
oh yeah I got something I don't get so
here's okay unless she's testing
the [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] if I found that
out on like the third date that we
thought is like yo what's wrong - I
thought of a scenario where I would get
mad if she if I told her like I can't do
Friday I'm [ __ ] busy she goes all
please it's gonna be so fun and she
presses the date on me and I'm not like
all right you know what for you they
around oh yeah I'll play my day around
this
let's do Friday one hour before the date
she does it [ __ ] I'm like I told y'all
is gonna be [ __ ] busy I did this [ __ ]
you [ __ ] do this [ __ ] on me
definitely I could get that guys seems
like an unbusy business
playing my whole day around this date I
need this like Nate man that's not the
way even the things that he chose chose
to I guess validate as time I already
showered already I already plucked my
eyebrows
that's one shave my legs [ __ ] it's
like some like really trivial [ __ ]
[ __ ] made [ __ ] yeah yeah so a lot of
people tend to gravitate to that shower
yeah portion of it and the guy showers
were like 5-10 minutes on both sides of
on one side is like it's like yeah dude
it's so you're telling me you wouldn't
have showered this day you didn't have a
date that's [ __ ] ridiculous on the
other side is people don't understand
the difference between a regular shower
in a date shower there's this bull print
like he shaved his balls he was some
mask Aidid yeah exactly like there was
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] ready
okay this other tweet it says if I had
received this cancellation and I had
just shower and was getting ready there
were there would be no rescheduling how
people treat you at the beginning is the
best they will ever they ever will the
text would have been no thanks for best
of luck with the launch you both lucked
out but it was work like dude it's work
no the work thing too a lot of people
brought up the fact that if she's
already
she's already setting a precedent of
that the fact that she will be picking
work over anything not really though I
don't see it that way because it's like
you don't know this person what if it
doesn't work out but you drop everything
for them first that that to me sounds
reckless yeah cuz I work and the first
date yeah it's different from your state
and work and your wife yeah we're
anniversary so it slowly builds like it
starts here and then it builds to like
family is way over work later on and
well we don't know if it's a first date
but then like further further go into
this whole work thing in this article
they're talking about the fact that like
if she is she is dropping let's say
she's a leader in this company and she
is dropping her personal plans she is
showing everyone else in the company
like hey
personal life is more important to work
and then whatever like she's setting
that precedent for her works they're
more important to personal life exactly
or the other way around and
let's say she's not in a higher-up
position and she's like trying to climb
her way up and then she proves to
everyone else in her work environment
that work is the most important thing as
she will go above and beyond and like
that will set sets unreasonable
expectations for herself in the future
so I guess there's like a little [ __ ]
though no matter what he's a bit that
response is some bitch-ass [ __ ] but he
put a lot of people are viewing it the
fact that he respects himself so much
that that's to know respecting man well
why do a woman like that it's projection
like if anything he should just been
like listen I hear what you're saying
like send me a picture of your boobs and
we'll call yeah I was gonna get
something tonight yeah give me something
to Jack because if you reply like Tim
said oh cool yeah what's that she'll
like well you owe me a [ __ ] that
won't be scheduled till next week and
then cry it off to the wall like the
fact that he got that type of emotional
response and let it pass through his
text that's what shows that he's pitched
me oh I would have just been like oh man
I was looking forward to it but
congratulations that's [ __ ] cool
let's hang out next time and if she
really wants it she'll come to me thanks
then you swipe some more on tinder
what's the big deal you guys aren't
steady like the hostage that upset over
this and he really has like such high
respect for himself to the point where
it's like 1,000 he's a bit he's insecure
let's just go with that narrative that
he respects go himself and that he's got
his whole body lasered before exactly
he's just like listen I'm a guy and
she's lucky to be with me whatever the
[ __ ] she could you did not have to
respond this way I agree he could have
just been like nope and then peace out
I'm done we're good
like there's no need to literally shout
out the fact that it's the fact that
he's showered and Klima the whole day
around there poised to pull out is
silver disrespectful I agree that's like
too much yeah one text I agree
but he's like you're Sagittarius and
this is really unlike you
but then also they're pointing out in
this article the fact that yeah like
that text exchange can cause a whole
discussion but the simple fact that this
chain
decided to tweet it out to the world
also shows a lot of her character too
because there's no need to yeah that's
how people do now yeah they're both
pretty immature then yes like if she
would've just left it at that then I
didn't I would have any cool but the
fact that she had to air it out that's
weird yeah she wanted to teach the world
something correct yeah this is how men
act like all [ __ ] men I miss when
people used to just share their launcher
online like taking a picture you know
what and my problem is I made fun of
that [ __ ] back then I shouldn't know and
now you got to deal with this [ __ ] yep
now the people just sharing everybody
you can make fun of this even more like
I don't think there's anything wrong
with setting boundaries and being up
front in the beginning but yeah like the
way he lashed out was long
yeah I'm still on her side for sure yeah
same Jeff I think they both are dumb I
think they're both yeah they're both
pretty [ __ ] dumb but that's why
they're on camera how people get into
their minds that he's respecting himself
by talking like by whining to her you
know the only can he say the only way
that would be red flag the only way that
would be cool is if that was Jeff Bezos
it's like he's busy you know what
he's busy you are a very busy man this
one shower is very important yeah make a
billion dollars a day or some [ __ ]
[ __ ] makes 125 million dollars every
30 minutes if you waste his time you
just wasted a billion dollars I mean
come on yeah I get it
that's why you become the side chick but
if your jet Bezos while you're texting
this there's also a girl giving a
[ __ ] in underneath the table that's
true
dude you're like I can't believe you're
wasting my [ __ ] time no there's three
Brazilian Mazal fighting to suck your
dick suck your dirty unshowered [ __ ]
yeah they want to clean it with their
mouths that's disgusting
smegma
[Music]